ragazzi fermi fermi ci sono delle volte
in cui uno spende dei soldi per delle
motivazioni reali importanti di questo
gioco ragazzi to impersoni un cappello
un cappello coi baffi io ho speso dei
soldi per comprare questo gioco dove
impersona un cappello coi baffi e ho
speso 13 euro
vediamo ok a sono controlli ma questo e
con più ha quindi sono contro il
computer io penso di fare perché sarà ho
comprato sto gioco che si potrà giocare
in multiplayer e non aveva un senso solo
fare da colorare la gente c'è il massimo
di colori che riesci a tutti di colorare
la gente ok ma la gente che tu devi
colorare quella che quei bollini in
testa vi spiegate stesso di questo gioco
ho speso 13 euro per colorare delle
persone sedute sulle panchine va bene ma
io posso togliere i colori agli altri di
poco che è successo era una roba per
distrarli ma va a cagare
io voglio togliere i colori agli altri
posso farlo non lo posso fare tipo gli
altri hanno americano colori li tolgo
così almeno torno io primo giusto o sto
dicendo una cacata non ho capito c'è uno
credo colorarli eccolo aia ok ok giusto
togli i colori agli altri torri e gli
altri sei primo non è vero solo prima si
perdono le verdi fino a darci birdie e
togliere i colori e verdi perché sono
ruja a punteggio giusto e corretto come
sto facendo
quando tu colori uno che al bollino in
testa prendi il colore lo puoi mettere
anche sugli altri che non ho capito cosa
prova che mi riprendo adesso sta facendo
un casino
abbiamo fatto cagare perfetto devo
togliere punti ai verdi ma con ai verdi
se mi stanno spaccando il culo lega è
difficilissimo ma anche i rossi non
scherzano
andate a cagare ai acqua
lo yacht io continuo a non capire se sei
salito togliendo agli altri anche non
poteva non capirla questa roba comunque
veramente difficilissimo ragazzo
iniziato negli sprint solo alla fine
maledizione perché alla fine sono
diventato bravissimo porca vacca vinto
il verde aiuta ma sarà come l'eroe già
ayane
se la conquisti guadagni un sacco di
punti probabilmente non sapevo parlare
per la prima partita sono arrivato
secondo non è male si chiama makeup on
adesso di schifo lari faccio perché sono
convinto di poterlo battere e solo per
questo motivo un e sociali lo fai con i
mega questo 20 sono papà vegas
questa volta uno studio globale italia
un sacco gianpi ma lo voglio fare perché
proprio è più forte di me ok acquisto
poi perché devi questo devi conquistarla
e non ho capito che cosa ti dà alla fine
ma occhio ai a c'è male togliti l'ho
conquistato ok perfetto minato
arcobaleni che non ho capito cosa
significano ha forse poi colora e tutti
proprio verrai tutti a cai tipo il turbo
di supermario la bella signori saluta
del capolista
ciao e stato bello ragazza bella partita
bravi complimenti
no non potevo per ragazzi non potevo
perdere la gente ma per lui proprio come
ho fatto con gli iscritti con youtube
italiana spera che questa tagliamo
raccogli alla lava si alza questa
difficile nel raccogliere le monete nel
mentre che si alza la lava o capito però
la domanda è dove vado ci vado lo spazio
sulle persone normali cioè le monete me
le prendo la genere dalla gente quindi
qualsiasi persona mi damone do che ora
rimangono sopra che non ne frega perché
sa perché sotto c'è ovviamente di gente
a ok va bene
occhio che si sta alzando narrava occhi
occhi occhi occhi occhio che la madonna
mi sono salvato fortissimo aiuto tutto
cash da occhio questa e passa con le
pazze scema di un becco la gente stupida
sono sopra i tetti aiuto ho cambiato
postazione madonna che volo fatto buono
ma la tensione torna indietro non certo
punto no ragazzi sono primo ma non me la
sto per niente che aveva tanto questa
sembra proprio l'italia c'è e veramente
l'italia questa di me la verità no dirò
io morando aiuto no a modo nostro
sono morto che è male mamma mia non ho
perso la che positano è invece apprezzo
tantissimo aperto persona partita rega
porto demonio sapevo i soldi li come hai
fatto a prenderli ho perso la partita
perché la lava mi ha tolto tanti di quei
soldi che non so che fa morto dimora che
stupido porco del demonio è
difficilissimo ragazzi e tutta la ma
cosa faccio vado sui soldi e poi muoio
lì però attenzione attenzione cosa punto
mi seguono anche giocato procedete ho
fatto
per i soldi perché ho beccato una volta
la lana ma allo stesso tempo preso un
sacco di soldi
quindi non è andata male no il prestito
prese alla fine ho detto io abito io ho
colpito la lara ma non me li ha tolti ho
vinto io ragazzi ho fatto una partita
incredibile perché li ho presi poi li ho
persi i [ __ ] presi io ho vinto
non ho capito niente di quello che è
successo questo era bello dall'ava trova
arcobaleno what devo trovare la linke
senso non ho capito cosa vuol dire cosa
vuol dire aiuto spiega te li devi
trovare l'arcobaleno devo colorare la
gente o no si correrà la gente non ho
capito che sono dietro l'arco valeva è
quella persona lì che è fatta di tutti i
colori che ogni tanto spunta immagino
che sia spuntata sentendo questo rumore
dove arcobaleno non lo vedo aiuto a
taylor renderle sopra ecco vedi che
adesso arriva da un altro sicuro fame
contro la c'è qualcuno che c'è
l'arcobaleno addosso non lo vedo ragazzi
difficilissimo
dai eccolo ho trovato io ho tratto io
seguo non toccatemi fate schifo ti ho
fatto hanno trovato io ho vinto
fortissimo ho trovato fatto un sacco di
punti giusto credono ma togliti che fai
cagare chuter come viene qua togliti
giallo fai schifo aia [ __ ] e
togliti sono andato se cagato sotto
scarone ce l'ho fatta rho gamer
allora quando ciò l'arcobaleno
teoricamente secondo me devo puntare a
quelli che non hanno il mio colore
perché in qualche modo li di accesso
oppure a nuovo quando è al governo
colpisce più gente intorno a te a avevo
capito sua roba finite esageratamente
strano sono veramente forte come ho
fatto il doppio di quello di sotto c'è
siamo né prove e l'aiuto alle persone
oddio e che ne so io devo trovare una
persona esata eccola né questa agli a
pezzo di merda ma è acqua e questa non è
questa la novità reperito dei soldi non
era quella porco demoni anche il vestito
del suo ruolo
mica è difficilissimo se dovessero quale
pure il vestito la partiamo dal vestito
aia che fastidio vestito marrone ma non
la trova difficilissimo capelli neri
magris ex eccola niente come lo vedo
anno non ha preso un altro
ciò neanche la speranza eccolo
non so panchina ahi ahi 8 niente
neanche a me l'ha fatto prendere pet set
schifo ultimo salvato ultimo faccio
pagare in questo gioco non lo voglio
neanche la classifica la rifacciamo di
questa ragazza l'unica che non ho vinto
mi sento proprio in dovere di farla le
facciamo la cia ci devo provare con
tutto me stesso è difficilissimo allora
quel vestito capelli marroni
eccolo quindi togliere testa di culo
primo mio regalo
buono il sito blu vestito blu vestito
blu dove jack ed è stato dato eccoli
eccoli vittoria di morgan
morite oddio mio spazzati tutti glia
fortissima ma io ho usato il mio potere
non fare ma come io ho usato il mio
potere ma cosa dai ragazzi ora che ho
usato il mio potere cuoce senza il
potere se non lo prendo manco col potere
questo è guarda che fini di sua madre
cappello capelli rossi eccolo che male
ma come mi ha tolto tutti sti soldi ma
cosa che mi sta togliendo i soldi basta
la nota un sacco di soldi non so chi sia
stato
no sono secondo di nuovo perché non toto
i milioni di pazienti me la rega
incredibile mi hanno tolto un sacco di
soldi a quest'ora avevamo vinto forcole
monio basta togliermi i soldi ma anche
al 30 secondi lega che partita
incredibile
ecco ecco la vedo male non la vedo il
giallo lo vado a prendere pezzo di me sa
pinto il giallo
non parole ha vinto il giallo
[Musica]
brutti pezzenti schifosi di un laido
guarda signori questo gioco che ti rende
tranquillo meno male che non ho giocato
con dei miei amici siamo questionari ha
verificato i cazzotti in bocca però va
bene niente ceramisti sia piaciuto
iscrivere a calare ricordatevi indossate
sempre il cappello e siate colorati
nella vita e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]